à fort de france la violence a toujours
été une affaire de rue mais la violence
par armes à feu devient pour les anciens
des terres sainville une question de
génération moi j'étais jeune j'ai pas
connu ça j'avais même peur de le faire
quand je vois un fusible que j'étais
jeune je me cachais je voulais pas ma
bouche et maintenant les enfants
possèdent dix amants et même des hommes
de guerre c'est la loi de la jungle la
loi du plus fort donc voilà une âme mais
on est bien c'est la guerre ça devient
un phénomène de mode et que les jeunes
et moins jeunes ont pas conscience de
cela
la bo du de déposer les hommes mais ce
ne sont pas les mauvaises hommes qui
sont déposées c'est ce qu'ils utilisent
pas les sommes qu'ils déposent les
dégâts les bagarres les règlements de
compte ont toujours existé mais un beau
scandale par exemple les anciens se
défendent avec d'autres armes
il n'y avait pas à avoir autre chose que
ce qu'on possédait à l'époque son
vocabulaire sa force physique en faisant
un combat on était comme si c'était un
monde d'amener une coiffe hansson ou
quoi vous même et puis ça s'arrête là
dans le gard google c'est la bagarre il
va prendre son arme
c'est l'évolution ils ont évolué mais
dans le négatif nous les anciens on les
évite veut pas collaborer avec eux
puisque c'est pas le même dialogue
moi personnellement jeune de 17 ans 18
ans va m'appeler papilles les papillons
rappelle à papier et terol a donc ya pas
il n'y a pas cette forme de respect car
depuis l'arrivée du crack dans les
années 90 puis plus récemment la
banalisation des armes à feu cette
violence est transformé
vêtus de tee shirts dans l'opposition il
s'offre à son fusil pour qu'ils se font
agresser la chute à moto revue n'y aura
point 500 me levant le poing depuis le
mois de janvier
quinze personnes ont été tuées par
balles en martinique une criminalité
galopante pourtant largement dénoncée
depuis 2013